if you're dreaming of a trip to Europe
yes I am You Are Not Alone tourists are
back in a big big way at some of the
most iconic locations across the
continent that's after a rough few years
during this pandemic Chris livesay is in
Rome which has a few you could say
iconic locations of its own Chris lucky
you you get to see this all the time
good morning to you
that's right Gail good morning you know
gone are those Dog Days of covid when
tourism to euros came to a screeching
halt you know many thought last year was
the rebound when a staggering 600
percent more Americans came here than
the year before but this year is setting
new records
sizzling heat and more Americans than
you can shake a selfie stick at there
are so many people
compared to last year a whopping 55
increase in tourists from the U.S is
jamming up landmarks from Paris to
London and Rome
the traffic and the crowds have never
been crazier fortunately there are still
a few shortcuts
Andiamo
it's called Vespa sidecar tour it's like
Chariot racing
and like Ben Hur before us business is
charging ahead the founder Luca Di
trapano tells me you've never seen
anything like this before it's crazy a
far cry from the deserted cobblestones
of covet lockdowns in recent years
after that the people really wanna leave
us have they making up for lost time
because of covid I think so
I think so I think that they were
wearing this and so were local
businesses says Giuseppe rocholi the
head of the Rome hotels Association I
say it's a Magic Moment a Magic Moment
yes after
almost three years that or all the
hotels in Rome 99 percent was closed it
now they're making up for lost time room
prices are up 20 percent in Rome 30
percent in London and 50 percent in
Paris while lines to main attractions
can seem endless as one guide warns us
that can be longer longer one hour two
hours two hours of course wow okay and
some people in those lines are out of
line this tourist is using a key to
carve his and his girlfriend's name into
the Coliseum
to the shock of onlookers
a crime that could cost him more than
sixteen thousand dollars in fines or
even five years in prison
bad apples aside most are just thrilled
to finally be among the people again is
everybody loving in or is anyone kind of
like
[Applause]
and living La Dolce Vita
and nothing says Roman Holiday like a
ride in a Vespa now as for that tourist
who scratched the graffiti into the
Coliseum his Roman holiday is over
police have found him he lives in the UK
and they say he faces up to five years
behind bars Nate
hope that's a lesson learned sidecar
Chris in Rome thank you so much we
appreciate you so very happy that the
guy with the graffiti is not an American
I was like not an American police not an
American please you know what Tony I
said exactly the same thing I said
please don't let it be an American five
years seems a little stiff but I also
think you have to respect other people's
culture of course their history and
their country I was so disappointed when
I saw that he did that and I also like
that somebody chastised him and said are
you serious man yeah that's right not
cool not cool at all